you
there were emotional moments at last
night's Golden Globes awards including a
tribute by Saturday Night Live's kate
mckinnon - ellen degeneres of course
attitudes changed but only because brave
people like ellen jump into the fire to
make them change and if I hadn't seen
her on TV I would have thought I could
never be on TV they don't let LGBTQ
people on TV and more than that I would
have gone on thinking that I was an
alien and that I maybe didn't even have
a right to be here so Thank You Ellen
for giving me a shot MacKinnon thank to
generous for paving the way for gay and
lesbian artists like herself and
presented her with the special Carol
Burnett award the rest of the nights off
favorites and underdogs take home prizes
including once upon a time in Hollywood
and 1917 Entertainment Tonight host
Kevin Frazier was at the awards show he
joins us from the et set in Los Angeles
Kevin the globe's love to keep us
guessing don't they each and every year
you know Anthony I was backstage rubbing
elbows with a mix of frontrunners and
Dark Horse's and you know a lot of
people expected Renee Zellweger's win
for her portrayal of Judy Garland
but Taran Edgerton who played out in Jon
and Rocket Man beat out the likes of
leonardo dicaprio eddie murphy and so
many more but Leal's movie was one of
the nights biggest winners once upon a
time Best Picture winner once upon a
time in Hollywood
is writer director Quentin Tarantino's
revisionist history of the 1969 Manson
murders it focuses on a fading TV star
and his stunt double I can't say I
really know how you played by Golden
Globe winner Brad Pitt before the show
Pitt told me the night was more about
seeing old friends than winning an award
we're the same age how come you still
have all that damn here 19:17 won Best
Picture in the drama category it also
won Best Director for Sam Mendes who
filmed it to appear as if the entire
movie was just one continuous shot sorry
Tom Hanks got emotional when he saw his
family in the audience while accepting a
Lifetime Achievement Award
a badess bless a mattes bless where the
family sitting down front like that
awkwafina awkwafina made history as the
first woman of Asian descent to invest
Actress in a comedy or musical for the
farewell she told me the
multi-generational family saga resonated
across all cultures we're all connected
by love and loss and especially the love
that we have for our grandparents as the
Joker Joaquin Phoenix's descent into
madness earned him Best Actor in a Drama
while Taryn Edgerton won in The Musical
or Comedy category portraying Elton John
working in films to be portraying an
icon and then to win an award for it
it's that is quite actually literally
the stuff that dreams are made of leg
Zellweger also won for portraying an
icon Judy Garland solidifying her status
as an Oscar frontrunner as Judy stole
inside you because you did morph into
her how how do you get that out of you
oh I don't want you to have learned all
of that and spent so much time digging
through the treasure and her legacy i'ma
hold onto that you know Renee really is
fabulous in that role I'm by the way
once upon a time in Hollywood one big
but it did not earn a Best Director
trophy for Quentin Tarantino as we
mentioned that went to Sam Mendes for
1917 and the director category courted
some controversy because all the
nominees were men yeah even Sam Mendes
sure looked shocked Kevin Gervase was
back hosting for the fifth time and he
sure kept the censors busy last night
what was the reaction backstage well
Anthony here's the thing he doesn't play
his shtick for the room or the people in
that room he does it for the audience at
home and so I believe that even though
Ricky walked up to the line and stepped
over it he will be back again in the
future as long as he wants to Craig
Kevin will be back because that's what
they want
thanks a lot you're right I'm Hanks and
Ellen DeGeneres the best the best bye
Kevin
all right we'll be right back bye
Anthony
you